what the [ __ ] is inflation we keep
hearing about it but what actually is it
imagine a village that has one market
where people buy all of their stuff
their food their clothes but one day the
government shows up because they're
worried about the economy of this
Village so they tell the people that if
they want to take out a loan and they're
going to make sure that the banks will
not charge them a high interest rate
they want to encourage the people to
take out loans and spend money oh and
they also drop off a giant pile of cash
for everyone in the village and everyone
in the village is like sweet I'm feeling
pretty rich villagers now are going to
their market and they're buying way more
stuff many of them have been eyeing the
fancy electric bike in the market that
before they couldn't justify but now
they totally can because they have all
this new money the store owners like
sweet this is great for business but
he's running out of bikes in fact he's
running out of everything because now
all of these people have extra money and
they're buying way more than they used
to the store owner's like I can't keep
up with all this demand I should raise
prices and that is inflation